JAMES: So I'm super excited
to have Vicki Abeles-- did
I get it right?
VICKI ABELES: Yes.
JAMES: Close?
VICKI ABELES: Close enough.
JAMES: Excellent, yes--
uh-oh, close enough--
to have Vicki here.
She's an inspiration.
She began her career as
a Wall Street attorney
and turned filmmaker
in 2007 when
she co-directed the
award winning documentary
"Race to Nowhere."
Which is more than a
film, it's more a phrase
now used by parents--
a rallying cry.
It's a vivid portrayal of
the pressure cooker culture
dominating American schools,
which you got a taste
of in the videos we showed.
So Vicki showcased
"Race to Nowhere"
in more than 7,000 community
sponsored screenings--
including multiple
showings at Google years
ago-- to millions of
viewers around the globe.
She is also the
author of a book.
There it is.
After you read this book it
will be full of post-it notes,
I guarantee you.
She's an-- amazing book,
"Beyond Measure," which is also
a documentary of the same name.
Which builds on
"Race to Nowhere,"
by looking at
practical solutions
that you can take in your
homes, classrooms, and school
districts.
Starting tomorrow or even today.
So Vicki's films and books were
a wake up call in our family
and in our district where the
film was shown-- both films.
And it served as a rallying
cry to make a difference
in the lives of our children and
the students of our community.
So Vicki, welcome to Google.
VICKI ABELES: Thank you.
JAMES: So I'm going to let
you do most of the talking.
And in a little bit we're going
to introduce a special Googler
to join us.
But I want to start with
the thought of producing
not one film but two.
And authoring a book
is absolutely daunting.
Doing any one of those
three is daunting.
So talk about the
moment when you
were inspired to devote so
much energy to this task.
VICKI ABELES: Sure.
So about 10 years
ago my daughters
were in middle school,
fifth and seventh grade.
And as a parent I started to
see the pressures and the toll
that school was taking
on them and our family.
I saw two young girls
who went from being
happy, confident girls
who loved school.
To losing sleep.
To becoming anxious.
To waking up in panic attacks
during the middle of the night
about a test the next day.
And I started to wonder if
this was just my family.
So I started speaking to
families in my community.
And then eventually to families,
educators, health professionals
across the country.
And what I discovered
was an epidemic
of unhealthy, unprepared,
disengaged young people.
And then about six
months into my research
a young girl, 13
years old-- same age
as my oldest daughter-- took her
life after failing a math test.
And it was in that moment that
I knew I had to do something.
And so I thought to myself,
what if we could do something
to really listen to our
kids, give our kids a voice?
And those questions
are what ultimately
lead to "Race to Nowhere."
JAMES: That's amazing.
I can't think of
anything more motivating,
and I wish that's not what
it took to motivate change.
That kind of leads into the
second question, which is fear
is a powerful
motivator-- although we
spoke at lunch how
this really should
be about inspiring people.
So should parents be
scared about the health
of their children or see
a tremendous opportunity
to do something much better?
And if so, why is
either the case?
VICKI ABELES: So I don't
want to be an alarmist.
But here is what the data shows.
One in three students reported
to the American Psychological
Association that
they are stressed
and that that stress is
leading them to depression.
The number one source of the
stress cited by 83% of students
was school.
The CDC reports that the
majority of teenagers
in this country get two hours
less of sleep each night
than what's recommended.
And then in a recent survey that
we conducted in collaboration
with a pediatrician from St.
Louis at a local Bay Area
high school.
What we discovered
was really concerning.
We did a survey about the
wellness of that community.
Community surveying middle
class families, about
2000 high school students.
More than 50% of
those students we're
showing signs of moderate
to severe depression.
More than 50%.
I think what we have, James,
is a public health crisis.
On a scale that we have
yet to fully recognize.
And at the same time I think
that we need to use that data
and what we know-- even
annecdotatelly-- in our homes,
in our classrooms, in our
communities, to inspire action.
And just a quick
example-- you may
be familiar with this-- but
the Burbank school district
has taken these
issues seriously.
They've created a
wellness task force.
They now have a wellness center
at one of their high schools.
They adopted a suicide
prevention policy
in their district,
which involved
professional development for
all professionals ranging
from teachers to
administer to janitors.
And they are also addressing the
source of the unhealthy stress
in our kids lives.
Ranging from homework to AP
courses to too much testing.
So I'm really inspired by that
story and there are stories
like that.
Which you knew, we
write about in our book.
JAMES: Yes, well I want to
switch around a little bit
and talk about
wellness for a second.
So mindfulness is something
that has been taught
to thousands of Googlers.
As one of the
training programs we
get to take, addressing
stress is one of the things
we think about-- it's
part of our culture.
How have some of the
districts that you've
spoken to taken practical
steps on addressing stress?
VICKI ABELES: So we see a
number of districts and schools
and even teachers who are
adopting mindfulness programs.
Adding Yoga to the school day.
And I think that's
terrific and there
is great research to support
the benefits of that.
At the same time,
I am an advocate
for getting to the source
of the unhealthy stress.
And I think, unfortunately,
too many of our kids
are suffering from a
system and a culture that
values business-- and oftentimes
that means too much homework.
That values constant measurement
and the arms race to college.
And I think that it's really
incumbent upon all of us
as people who care for
students, for children,
to address those
unhealthy stressors.
And at the same time to add
programs like mindfulness.
JAMES: So that leads to the next
thought I have-- is all right,
so part of this is students
get caught up in the arms race
with their peers.
Feeling like it's a badge
of honor to lose sleep
and to take 10 AP classes.
Parents get terrified
about their kids
getting into the right school.
And everyone seems to be
trapped in this cycle.
So how do you
respond to this fear
of being disadvantaged
if you're the first one
to try to address this problem.
VICKI ABELES: Right, so I think
that's an excellent point,
is that no one really wants to
step off the treadmill first.
But we're at Goggle
here today and so
let's think about the
things that make people
at Google successful, right?
I imagine many people
at this company
are successful because
they're creative,
because they're
self-starters, because they
know how to get things done.
And unfortunately
our schools today
are set up in ways that our
kids spend most of their days
sitting in rows, consuming
information and regurgitating
it.
That's what we value in
many of our schools today.
And unfortunately we crowd
out the opportunity for them
to develop the very skill
that are going to serve them,
not just in college and their
future employment, but in life.
And so, you know, what
I find really inspiring
are those schools that we
have followed these last three
years in the film "Beyond
Measure" and in the book,
that are taking
steps to re-imagine
what's possible in our school.
And I think that's the question
we need to ask ourselves.
What if we design schools in a
way that prioritized wellness
and learning?
JAMES: So that in the movie
you have some amazing examples
of innovation around schools
changing-- charter schools,
public schools,
that didn't really
seem to be the
factors-- just schools
that took that first step,
not just the individual
but-- what are some of the most
inspiring examples of schools
that have taken that leap of
faith and seen it at least
head the right direction.
VICKI ABELES: Right, so
we've visited schools that
are taking steps big and small.
What I want to
highlight is the process
of change, the process that
creates change is really
what we want to be focusing on.
And it's critical
that that process
include all of the stake
holders in a community.
Ranging from students--
students need
to be an important voice
in these conversations,
they need to inform the design
or the redesign of the school.
In fact, in all of the schools
that we feature in our new film
students were an integral
part of the design process.
You need to engage the
superintendents, the community
members.
I think everybody needs to be
a part of this conversation.
There is no greater resource
and important issue,
I think, than addressing
the well-being of our kids
and their preparation
for their future.
JAMES: So what have you
learned to help students break
this cycle even if their
parents are pushing them
and even if the districts
are pushing them.
And I think when we get to Ken
that there's a great example
of that locally.
But where they get into the
idea that this studying late
at night and even
pretending to go
to sleep-- as you wrote
about-- and having wake
up in the middle of the
night doing homework
when their parents
think they're asleep.
What are some of the ways
to have students believe
it's in their best interest?
VICKI ABELES: Well,
so one of the ways
to have them believe it's
in their best interest is
to tell them stories
of people who
have taken alternative paths.
To really convince
them that it's not
the name of the college
that one attends that
determines your success in life.
And in fact, what colleges,
what employers are looking for
are people who are passionate.
People who are interested.
People who want to
contribute something
positive to the world.
That being said, you know, I
think there's a lot of things
that individuals can do in
their home-- both parents
and students.
You know, from modeling balance
as parents for our children.
To encouraging our children
to not over schedule
both academically and in
terms of extracurriculars.
But I also think that puts a
lot of burden on individuals.
And what I want to
say to you, James,
is that I think the individuals
are responding right now
to the culture
that exists, right?
And if you are a parent
with a child in school,
school is the culture.
And that culture really impacts
your family and your student.
And so that's why I'm a big
advocate for a school change
as well.
I think that we need
to move away from what
has become a blame game.
Of blaming college admissions,
of blaming helicopter parents
and say, the individuals
are responding
to the system and the culture.
And we all make up that culture.
And what we're trying to
do is to empower people
to change that culture.
And that takes a
different mindset
about the things that matter.
JAMES: So that kind of
leads to-- if you're
trying to implement
any kind of change,
if you're trying
to sell something,
you're going to run
into objections.
People are going to come up
with all kinds of reasons
not to do things.
It's human nature to
be static in some ways.
So what are some of the
most common objections
you hear, that you
expect to hear,
and how do you counter
those objections.
VICKI ABELES: So I think the
most common objection to things
like reducing the
number of AP courses
or reducing the
amount of homework
is our kids won't be prepared
for what's coming next.
And the reality is
research is very clear
that the best way to prepare
people for bad situations--
let's just say high
school homework-- is
to have lots of good
experience along the way.
But the other argument
that I'll make,
James, is that we know that our
kids are incredibly unhealthy.
They're sleep deprived, they're
anxious, they're depressed.
They're contemplating
suicide at increasing rates.
And at the same time we
hear from college professors
and from employers
that they're showing up
unprepared for the kind
of thinking and problem
solving that's needed.
So I don't really think
there is a reason for us not
to make the change.
Oftentimes, I think what
keeps us stuck in the status
quo is the mindset
that school is best
done as it's always done.
And it's incredibly--
you know, there
are a lot of stake holders
that need to come to the table
in order to make the changes.
JAMES: So before we bring
our next member of the panel
up here.
I want to finish the
questions directly to you
about the recommend-- you in the
book in a very practical way.
Which is great.
I think it's part of
the reason I think
you went from "Race to
Nowhere" to "Beyond Measure"
to give people a
sense of what to do.
So of the many
suggestions you make
at the end of the book, what
are a couple that you would--
for the people in
the Live stream,
here in the audience, who
watch this later on YouTube--
what are some steps
that they can take
starting tomorrow that you think
are the most practical, to just
get started.
VICKI ABELES: OK, so I've got
a long winded answer to that.
So big picture in our
schools, I think that we
need to consider three things.
We need to prioritize wellness.
And that means addressing
unhealthy stressors.
We need to recalibrate the way
time is spent in our schools
around a whole new
set of priorities.
And we need to transform
learning in our schools.
And each of us, parents,
educators, concerned citizens,
need to play a role in the
advocacy to make that happen.
As far as at the
individual level,
I just want to share a quote
from the film "Beyond Measure."
Sir Ken Robinson-- I
assume you know who he is--
says at the very end of the
film, if you're a teacher
and you change what you
do in your classroom
you have to changed
the education system
for the students in your class.
Now, I think that's a
really empowering thought.
As you know from
reading the book,
we share the story
of Mike Miller,
who is a teacher in Virginia.
And on his own once he
had his own children
decided to reduce
homework substantially
to make homework the exception
rather than the rule.
And to eliminate most
quizzes and tests.
And what he found is that
students in his class
did not become lazy
all of the sudden.
But, in fact, they
read more deeply.
They thought more deeply.
They wrote more creatively.
And so I think that thought
that Sir Ken Robinson
shares at the end of the
film applies to all of us.
Whether you're a parent,
a teacher, or a student,
we all need to be
advocates for change.
And so for anyone
here today, as well as
the people that are
listening, I would also
encourage you to get
this conversation started
in your community.
We are looking to want
a national conversation
about what's possible and about
the schools of the future.
And we've created a
lot of good resources
to engage a community
to share the research
behind these models that I think
are forward facing schools.
And better serve our
students and our teachers.
So I would just say get
involved, start a conversation.
Form alliances with
like minded people.
And create the change
that our kids need.
JAMES: And if you haven't
watched Ken Robinson's TED
talk on creativity it's
a must watch Google
and it's out on YouTube.
So I want to invite
up Ken Dower.
Ken is a Palo Alto Unified
School District board member.
And he's a Google
staff engineer.
I learned about Ken's
passion for education reform
from Vicki's book,
he was quoted.
He-- as I suspect
many of you know--
Palo Alto school district
is known for many things.
For it's education
excellence, it
is also known for its
tragic suicide clusters.
And Ken has a PhD in sociology
from the University of Arizona
and has on the ground experience
making a difference in Bay Area
schools.
And he's a board member at the
Paolo Alto school district.
He's also a consultant for the
U.S. Department of Education
and the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation,
to name just a couple of the
many things that he has done.
So I brought Ken
up here because he
can bring a local perspective
and he's also part
of "Beyond Measure" the book.
So I'm going to have the two of
you respond to these questions.
And you can chip in where
you think it make sense.
But we'll start with Ken.
So the Palo Alto
Unified School District
is known for its academic
achievements-- as I noted--
and suicide clusters.
How unique is this
story, in your research?
And I'm very interested in
your thoughts too, Vicki.
KEN DOWER: Well, I
think that-- I mean,
unfortunately, our experience
with suicide is unusual.
I think that it's our-- the
level of academic achievement
is pretty typical of
affluent suburban communities
across the United States.
I think that-- as
Vicki has talked
about-- the issues of
stress and sleep deprivation
and so forth are really
common across the country.
And the issues
that she is talking
about here and in the
book are really typical,
not just in Palo
Alto, but everywhere.
VICKI ABELES: And
I would just say,
fortunately, we don't see
lots of suicide clusters
but there are other across
the country happening
on some college campuses,
and high schools as well.
It's just Palo Alto seems to
have gotten a lot of media
attention of late.
But you, Ken, I believe that
the underlying conditions
that create the risk, they're
there in many communities.
We need to do
something about that.
Importantly-- I just want
to say-- those underlying
conditions that I mentioned
earlier, as far as
sleep deprivation,
anxiety, and stress,
not only are kids
unhealthy today,
but we are potentially setting
them up for life long disease.
And that is the reason, I think,
for people to pay attention.
And create action.
JAMES: Well, I
think another point
there is that depression can
be linked to sleep deprivation
but in fact it's the
other way around.
That sleep deprivation
can lead to depression.
So Ken, tie in--
talk a little bit
about how that
connection between all
the negative effects
of sleep deprivation.
KEN DOWER: Well, I think
that's absolutely right.
I mean, one of the
questions that people
had in the relation
between sleep deprivation
and depression, for
example, is which is causal.
And there have been studies
now that have really
teased that out and shown that
sleep has a-- lack of sleep--
has an independent effect.
It's not just that
being depressed
reduces sleep it's that--
or has an effect on sleep--
it's that loss of
sleep can really
have all kinds of
negative health effects.
On depression, on
things like propensity
to have a car accident,
on and suicidally,
on depressing
academic achievement.
What I really found in looking
at the research on sleep
over the last few years is
that if there is, to my mind,
if there's a sort
of silver bullet
that we could fasten on to
improve the lives of children
at school and academic
achievement it would be sleep.
And if you think about it from
a kind of policy perspective,
if we had policies that actually
worked to encourage sleep
we would be doing so
many positive things
in order to get there.
In terms of reducing
homework and, you know,
encouraging students-- and
having later start times--
encouraging students
to spend time
in the evening
with their families
and on the other pursuits
rather than homework.
All those positive things.
If we could really
move that needle,
they'd have the
direct effect on sleep
but they would
also have all kinds
of other positive effects.
VICKI ABELES: I
completely agree.
And indeed the American
Academy of Pediatrics
has recommended a later
start time of 8:30
for middle and high schools.
There are pockets of
schools that are adopting
that but not nearly enough.
And in their policy
recommendation
they also cite homework and
extra curricular activities
as things that get
in the way of sleep.
So from my perspective,
just going back
to the question
about one action,
I would say homework is
the low hanging fruit here.
Our kids, if you just take
a look at a day in the life
of a typical high
school student--
not an over scheduled student.
We can pick my son, for example.
Five or six academic classes,
they spend seven hours--
7 and 1/2 hours--
a day in school.
Right there, that's nearly
a 40 hour work week.
And then if you factor in school
sponsored extracurriculars,
just one extra curricular.
Whether that's a sports
team, a debate club, theater,
that's 15 to 20 hours
pretty typically these days.
Right there, you've
got a 60 hour week.
And then you add on
top of that homework.
And homework studies are
tricky because we're relying
a lot on self reporting.
But there is a study that
shows that students today
on average, high
school students are
getting 18 hours of
homework assigned to them.
And that assumes that
your child can do the work
in that amount of time.
That's become a third
shift for our kids
and I think it is
the single thing that
is getting in the way of sleep.
And it's also
preventing our kids
from developing in all
kinds of other ways
that are really important.
JAMES: You talk about
getting more sleep
and, Ken, you specifically
targeted zero period,
infamous zero period.
And went through
quite a struggle
to at least partially eliminate
zero period from Paul Alto
School District.
Including large
resistance from students.
Talk about how you approached
that challenge of making
the point you were trying
to make and have it
actually have some
tangible action at the end.
And how you worked
through those objections.
KEN DOWER: So this
was an issue that we
worked through a year ago.
And zero period is the period
before the start of the school
day.
So our high schools
changed their start times
several years ago to around
8:30 to encourage sleep.
But shortly after created
so-called zero periods
that start at 7:20
or so in the morning.
And one of our
high schools, Guns,
started to schedule a
number of academic classes
into zero period.
And we had about 300 students
in zero period at Gun.
And as Vicki said a year
and a half ago or so
the American Academy
of Pediatrics
came out with their
recommendation on school start
times of 8:30 or later.
Along with a whole really
overwhelming amount of research
that shows the serious negative
effects of earlier start times.
And so to me and
others in the community
this seem like an obvious,
to use Vicki's word,
low hanging fruit.
You know, why do
we have students
taking academic
classes in zero period.
So I raised this issue
at the school board.
Many local doctors eventually
weighed in on this.
I met with the pediatricians
at Palo Alto Medical Foundation
who saw this as an issue that
was of real concern for them.
And we advocated for a change
in our school district practice
to not have academic
classes in zero period.
We can get to the
other things that
are going on in zero
period as well, which--
and you'll be hearing about
the art of the possible at some
point in here.
But we did run into some
significant resistance
among students.
Hardly any among
parents, actually.
But among students.
And they organized,
very helpfully really,
a survey of students to say what
it was-- and one of the things
that they were asking
about, is what are students
getting out of zero period?
Why do they want zero period?
And when I looked at those
surveys and coded them up
for the reasons.
What I found is that
there were two reasons.
One is students were-- wanted
early morning classes so
that they could get
their homework done
earlier, because they
could leave school earlier.
And they also wanted
early morning classes
so that they could
finish school in order
to get to their
sports activities.
And to me what that
really meant is
that they were getting up
early as a coping strategy
for solving problems
that we really should
be solving for them, right?
We should not be creating
a situation where
kids feel like they have to get
up early so that they can get
to bed at a reasonable
hour because they have
so much homework after school.
And we should be arranging
their sports schedule
so that they can go to
school at a reasonable hour
finish at a reasonable
hour and then go on
to their competitions.
So to me what was clear is
that the student support
for zero period was largely
around solving problems
that we should be
solving more directly.
It's also the case, I think,
that students experienced it
as a sort of a lack of control.
And one of the things that I
think we're giving students
with the way they were
organizing life at school
is an experience
of lack of control.
You know, they just
don't have a sense
that they are in
control of their lives.
Because very often they're not.
I mean from morning
till night they're
doing things that they're
not really choosing to do.
And this felt to them
like a lack of choice,
sort of paradoxically.
But I think in real terms.
VICKI ABELES: And
I would just add
that the lack of choice of just
one more factor, I believe,
that contributes to depression.
And is out of sync with the
research around motivation
and what we know
supports motivation.
Giving people autonomy
and opportunity
is to have mastering
experiences.
And then, importantly,
I would also
add as far as the
depressed and anxiety, is
so much of their
student day-- not only
do they not have a
choice about it--
but often there is a
disconnect and no purpose seen
in what they're doing.
And so Bill Damon, a professor
at Stanford University,
writes a lot about this.
That is the lack of
purpose that is also
contributing to epidemic rates
of anxiety and depression.
So I think that's
also really important.
Giving our students more
choice and more opportunities
for connection between the work
that they're doing and meaning
in their lives.
KEN DOWER: So before I open up
to questions from the audience
and I'll check the Dory too.
Just to close off
thoughts from both of you.
So reading this book I
had to read it in chunks
because it got me very wound up.
Had to chill out a little bit.
It's a great book.
I encourage you to read it.
Just you may have to
read it in pieces.
Because it was both
inspiring in parts,
it was very
frustrating in parts.
And it's not hard for me feels
as a parent with a sophomore
that it's almost too late
for me to make change
for my younger daughter.
But I'm going to try to.
I'm going to do everything
I can to try to.
What gives you hope that
widespread change is possible?
VICKI ABELES: So everywhere I go
I'm inspired by fearless change
makers.
And people who are
starting to ask questions.
I think the frustration of any,
which I've experienced also
being that I've also-- my
youngest is now a high school
junior-- is that we need to
accelerate the rate of change.
And we need to make
it possible for people
to come forward with both their
questions and their ideas.
KEN DOWER: So I think that one
of the things that gives me
real optimism is that I
think in the past people
had seen health for
students and well-being,
and learning and achievement,
as two kind of opposed values.
And that we had to trade
off one against the other.
Right?
So if you want healthy students
and well-rested students
you have to-- the cost of
that is less achievement.
Right?
Less homework, less rigor.
And what I think is
really becoming clear
and well understood across our--
and certainly our community--
is that these are not opposed.
In fact, they're reinforcing.
That you really cannot have
students who are learning
and getting what we want them to
get out of school and have them
be sleep deprived and
anxious and depressed.
And those are really
inconsistent with each other.
So I-- and many
others in Palo Alto--
have really tried to
carry that message.
And I think it's a message
that people are hearing.
And I also agree with
Vicki that working
that into actual practice--
these are big entrenched
organizations.
You know, they're
not easy to change.
But it's possible.
You know, winning
election in school boards.
Forming parent groups.
Having local blogs that
focus on these issues.
Those are all things that
really make a difference.
Talking to your
parents teacher so
that they hear-- so that they--
so that their experience is
parents who want less rather
than parents who want more.
Those are all things that make
change possible to happen.
VICKI ABELES: I just--
real quickly-- and so,
I completely agree with you.
Health and learning
go hand-in-hand.
And our new film
features these schools
that are really creating new
and transformative learning
experiences.
So not just reducing
homework and assessment
but actually looking at the
research around how people
learn and making the
learning much more
hands on much more
meaningful, experiential.
So I would just encourage all
of you who are listening today
to help us take this to
a cultural conversation.
And to know there is a better
way to educate our kids
and prepare them
for their future
while not stealing their
childhood in the process.
AUDIENCE: Although we talk a
lot about the middle schools
and the high schools
making all these changes.
I'm just curious,
Vicki, how receptive
have the colleges been to
your research and your books
and movies.
And, you know, are they
open to these changes?
Because we can do
all of that here
but if you're all mindful
through middle school
and high school then
you get to college
and you can't even
keep up-- you know,
what's going to
happen to these kids?
It doesn't really matter now if
the colleges aren't open to it.
So I'm just curious how much
success you've had there.
VICKI ABELES: So I have a
long winded response to that.
But let me just
say that colleges
are seeing the
outcomes from this very
narrow vision for schooling.
And they're also
wanting the change.
So if you're not
familiar with this,
a couple months ago
a new report came out
from a consortium of colleges.
It's called "Turning
the Tide" and it's
making caring more common.
And so colleges
absolutely recognize
that we have a problem.
But like many of us,
I think they're also
afraid to go first.
Which is why doing these
things in collaboration
and as a movement
is so important.
You know, they are
seeing the outcomes
with wellness centers that
are beyond their capacity.
With students who are leaving
college their first year.
So as a parents, what I will say
with two daughters in college,
it's much more important
for our children
to show up at college with the
life skills that they need,
with the resiliency, and
with a passion for learning
not schooled out of them.
So colleges are absolutely
receptive to that.
And what I also want to
share is that we recently
screened "Beyond Measure"
at Olin College, which
is one of the colleges
featured in the film.
And I sat on a panel
with Liz Coleman,
who is the former president
of Bennington College.
And the question
posed to her was,
what is it going to take to
create an education revolution?
And Liz Coleman's response
was that we're not
going to have an education
revolution until we stop
seeing kindergarten
through 12th grade
as preparation for college.
Right.
What-- and then she went on
with a very provocative thought.
Which is what if K through 12
was so incredible that our kids
didn't need to go to college.
And so I would just
challenge all of us
to rethink what we're
doing in our schools.
To allow our kids to be present
with their experiences today.
And to know that that's
going to serve them
in the long run, whatever
their path may be.
JAMES: And I think I just
want to-- before we past
to any other questions-- I have
personal anecdote that I shared
with our school district.
That I don't know if I would
be a software engineer today
if I had had the amount
of homework kids have now.
What was I doing after
school when I had free time?
I was coding an
Apple II computer.
And I was absolutely
obsessed with that.
I was passionate about that.
If I had no time left
that passion would not
have had a chance to
flourish, except in the window
of the summer, which is pretty
well scheduled too today.
So that free time-- I think
there's a fear of free time.
That somehow that
free time is going
to be wasted if
left up to the child
to figure out what to do with.
What's missed there is that free
time may result in some boredom
and that boredom will eventually
get trounced by the desire
to do something
fun and creative.
And boredom is actually a
great trigger of creativity.
So in my own
personal experience I
can see a difference between
if I was a student now
I don't know if I would have had
the time to become a software
engineer in high school.
VICKI ABELES: And I
would also add to that
that those moments after school
when your kids are doing things
that they're interested in
and they're passionate about,
that's actually where the
self learning kicks in.
It's where the
perseverance kicks in,
when they're doing something
because they want to do it.
Where they learn those
skills that we all know
are so critical
for their success.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about homework policy
and pursuing changes with that.
You know, it's likely
to be most successful
as a collaborative process.
Where we involve a lot
of the stakeholders.
And I'm thinking we may
find some resistance
either from parents
or from teachers.
Do you have any perspectives
on who we might find resistance
from and how to
address that so that we
can continue to move forward?
VICKI ABELES:
Well, you're always
going to find people who are
opposed to change, right?
What we find is it tends to
be 10% to 20% of the people,
whether it's teachers or
parents-- who are opposed.
Right.
The rest of the people
really want the change.
And so what I would
say is within a school
make it optional, right?
I think just going back to
one of James's questions
about what's the most
inspiring change.
I think the opportunity to
create a school within a school
or school within a district
or a third grade class
within a Third grade
elementary, you know, program
at an elementary school.
And allow the people who are
ready for that kind of change
to opt in.
Allow the teachers
who are ready to teach
without assigning homework
and constant testing,
allow them to opt in.
And then let the parents
and students opt in.
And when other people see that
the world doesn't fall apart
and, in fact, kids come
to school much more
curious and creative rested.
I think you'll see those
changes start to spread.
But the reality is when
you're talking specifically
about homework I just
need to say-- going back
to the low hanging fruit--
there's no research to support
it an elementary school.
In middle school it's
very little research
to support it--
even in high school.
The OECD, which is the
organization that administers
the PISA test-- the
international test
that our kids participate in.
The countries,
first of all, that
lead the way in
those tests-- Finland
as an example-- assign
far less homework than we
do in this country.
And what the OECD has
concluded that in high school
after four hours
a week of homework
you see diminishing returns.
And we know that
many students are
suffering under the burden
of four hours a night.
So I think health is
so critically important
and that we begin to address it.
If you take homework
off the table
I've had pediatricians say you'd
see health outcomes improve
overnight.
And I think in that way we
would also free schools up
to begin to redesign
learning experiences.
KEN DOWER: Yeah, I
would agree with that.
I mean, I think homework
is a really fascinating
cultural phenomenon.
There is very little
evidence that it has,
as Vicki says, much of
an educational effect.
And certainly at the
levels that we see
are demonstrated to
have a negative effect.
Yet, we are consuming
enormous amounts of it.
It's kind of a mania almost.
I think it be well worth
delving into why that is.
And it has been a few-- I
was on the district homework
committee in Palo Alto
and one of the things
that we had to do was kind
of peel the sort of moral
and you know
dimensions of homework.
Homework is good
for kids because it
makes them
self-disciplined and you
know it teaches them
all these things
that there's no evidence that
it actually teaches them.
And if we were trying
to teach them that we
would have a curriculum for it.
We wouldn't just send
them home with a book
and hope that they
get through it.
I do think that, at least
our experience in Palo Alto,
is that there is no real
opposition to limiting--
to a policy that
limits homework.
I think the biggest
obstacle to change,
and what we really found, is
passing the policy was easy.
Implementing it has
been very difficult.
Not because of
organized resistance
but because of organizational
inertia, really.
And providing the tools
to make homework visible.
I mean, one of the
problems with homework
is that it happens at home
where nobody can see it.
So it's kind of an
unfunded mandate.
So making it even visible to
teachers and to administrators
is a step that we have to take.
In fact, that's
one of the things
I would really-- am pressing
on us to do next year.
Is to provide a feedback
mechanism that's reliable
so that teachers
can actually see
how much time is being spent.
Because it's hard
to control something
that you can't see or measure.
VICKI ABELES: Two
quick thoughts on that.
I think it's a great question,
and it's a really important
conversation that we need to
have in our school communities,
is what time belongs
to the family?
And I would argue that
weekends belong to the family.
Every weekend.
The idea that our kids are
working seven days a week,
that they never have a day
without something hanging
over their head-- and we
know from the research
that that is not the best way to
grow and develop all the things
that we care about, right.
So weekends, holiday breaks,
summer breaks and, you know,
I think that the next
step is our evenings.
We are not giving
our kids a choice
about going home in
the evening and putting
in that second or third shift.
Where we as adults
do have a choice.
And more flexibility and
room to navigate the demands.
And we're also adults.
These are kids and teenagers
whose bodies and minds
are still growing
and developing.
And you know there's something
really wrong with the idea
that we think it's OK for them
to be putting in a 70 hour
workweek.
To go back to your question
though in terms of resistance
or what support I would
just say is needed in order
to make these changes.
I actually think that
professional development
is needed for teachers.
Because if you take
homework off the table
that's an integral part
of many teachers practice.
And what we have
found in the schools
that we visited that have
eliminated homework, when
the principals
speak to us candidly
they say it's actually not
the parents who are resisting,
it's many of our teachers.
And so I would just
recommend anybody
who wants to have
this conversation,
Dr. Etta Kralovec at the
University of Arizona
is an expert in this space.
She loves to do professional
development for teachers.
She just is online today with
an interview about eliminating
all homework K through 12.
And I would argue to make it the
exception rather than the rule.
AUDIENCE: I really
agree with everything
you've said so far on the
well-being of students and kind
of changing the culture
of your classroom
so that students are not just
regurgitating what you're
teaching but really hands on.
So that was my approach going
in to my Pre-Calc class.
But throughout the
semester I was kind of
torn because students were
preparing for the AP Calc test
next year.
And at the end of
every year there's
these standardized testings
and I realized that
even though the students
enjoyed the culture
and they were learning, as
I can tell, in our class.
They were struggling with the
actual wording-- reading--
understanding what the
standardized questions were
asking.
You know, so I taught the
math in a different way
than how the
standardized testing was
asking the questions and I
saw a huge struggle in that.
And while on one hand, I really
want to keep that culture
and promote their
learning like hands on.
But on the other
hand, I didn't want
to be the person that
let them fail the test
and not be able to go to a
good college or something
because that's still the
way our education system is.
So I'm just wondering from your
point of views, both of you,
what are your thoughts on that?
KEN DOWER: Well,
so, this is an issue
that I've talked about a
little bit on the school board,
is that the cost of
standardized tests
and AP tests and
things like that
is that we take
teachers like you who
bring their own particular
gifts and interests and passions
and we divert them
towards serving goals
that are formulated elsewhere.
A curriculum that's
developed in New Jersey
is going to be less good,
you know, for students then
a curriculum that's
developed by the teachers who
are standing in front of them.
And that is a response to
what their interests are.
So I think that's kind
of the hidden costs
of this level of standardization
that we're seeing.
VICKI ABELES: I
completely agree.
I would love to speak
to you afterwards.
We're actually just
finishing up a film examining
math education in this country.
And the experts in that
film are real advocates
to transform what we're
doing in our math classrooms
to a direct and much more
in line with what you just
described.
JAMES: Thank you, again,
for taking your time today
to share this important topic.
VICKI ABELES: Thank you, James.
[APPLAUSE]